societies are built off of families
is it good for society and people in
general to have baby mamas left and
right is that good is that good for a
family is that a healthy situation for a
kid to grow up in if you have people who
aren't understanding who aren't
compassionate and who aren't able to
provide love then no I would say it's
not a good Society but I think our
society do you think in general just in
general
would you say in general it's good for a
kid to be raised by a single mother in
general just yes or no I would say that
yesterday but this is this is kind of
relative no no I know I know but I need
I just need I think it can be I think it
can be it just depends on the community
that's around them okay okay it really
doesn't it does even even though that
puts a kid even though even though that
puts a kid at every statistical
disadvantage they're more likely to run
away from home they're more likely to
drop out of school because we live in a
system that doesn't support single
mothers doesn't support
it okay how do you not support single
mothers when if you get pregnant you can
have an abortion and you get free
housing if you get pregnant I think if
you're a single mother
that doesn't happen to men they're just
homeless
they're just homeless there's a there's
an issue with that too I think we all
deserve compassion and we deserve to
live in a society where everyone has
their basic human rights
for it who pays for it like that's a
conversation we need to start having
it's a conversation we genuinely need to
start having if we want everyone to live
at a certain standard and actually be
able to live and then how do we how do
we like why do I have to pay for someone
who made poor decisions like if you
chose to be a single mother I didn't
choose to do that I I damn well could be
pregnant right now like why do I have to
pay for someone else's bad decision you
made that decision and like oftentimes
we try to take accountability off of
women and we stop them from facing the
consequences of your decisions like that
was a decision you made no and and I
agree I think everyone should have
accountability but that we also can't
place blame on people but that comes
with accountability it's blame
but when when you place the blame right
wouldn't working out how we could make a
better system like accountability is
saying that was my fault and taking
blame so like even earlier when they
were being accountable they were saying
yeah I'm taking the blame so so
collectively educating people to not
make those decisions right to make
decisions no I think women are educated
we just choose not to I mean you you
know what you're doing when you have sex
you know when you're ovulating you you
know if you're if you're on birth
control or not on birth girl you know
all of these things and you make a
choice I would I would say the
intelligent the the way we are educated
maybe is kind of the wrong Focus because
we're not educated go around emotional
you know emotional stability we choose
men who leave or we choose men who
aren't going to stand up because like
you said last time that we we choose to
ignore red flags right and I think
there's a lot of factors that go into
that right and we aren't really taught
you know about how our relationships
with our parents or how our you know
primary relationships really govern the
relationships that we choose right and
so a lot of us go through that kind of
space not being aware of what we're
choosing and I'm not saying that removes
accountability I say you have to be
accountable but if we can create a
system that teaches people about these
Dynamics we can stop that from happening
I think women we just don't care I mean
I I have sat down with friends and said
yo
here's red flag number one here's red
flag number two I here's a PowerPoint on
why this isn't gonna work and and women
we don't care because when we when we
like a guy we just See No Evil Hear No
Evil right and and if you end up in a
bad situation you get pregnant by that
guy like it doesn't matter women don't
care as a matter of fact last time when
you were on the show I read a bunch of
Statistics as to when it comes to single
mothers right but then hang on I read a
bunch of Statistics as to why single uh
children born of single mothers are
statistically a disadvantage when it
comes to homelessness when it comes to
prison when it comes to adoption when it
comes to all of these things and still
even with all the statistics people find
a way in which to justify a reason to
become a single mother right and it's
like
when you speak I'm not saying that you
know what you're saying isn't valid I'm
saying regardless after you speak the
statistics are still there but I would
ask they are still there but like I said
last time I would say there are other
factors that go into that there are
factors of the system right people
living in poverty people living in
circumstances that they aren't able to
properly give support to a child right
and I'm not saying that Society has to
step up and necessarily support that I
think we should live in a more
Collective and collaborative Society
where everyone puts in the same amount
of effort I think I should have five
million dollars in my bank account but I
don't I don't think that's relevant to
what I was saying I hope it happens I
think you think you think but the
reality is different yeah you know what
I'm saying so the reality is different
but how can we shift the reality if we
don't think if we don't don't think I
had to the way we can do things better
the way we can support people better
right how can we change the world we're
in to to help people live if we don't
think about that if we don't have these
I would say by taking accountability for
your decisions and saying don't sleep
around with men you don't want to be
fathers with I like and I'm saying I'm
saying like take accountability for the
lot your lot in life hey if you get
pregnant and you're a single mom no
one's bailing you out because that's a
poor decision yeah like I and I think
that would remove that would like even
we had um this grandma on here Auntie
Auntie Jenny and she was saying like
people in her day would get pregnant
because they wanted to move out of their
house and the government got them a
house in my day yeah in my day women
would get pregnant just so they can get
flat just so they can get an apartment
and yeah because because UK government
would give you an apartment if you were
a single mother and I think you have a
really positive like world view where
you think maybe people won't take
advantage of that but they do no and I'm
I'm aware of that and I I do know that I
have a very you know I I'm aware of it
within myself it's not Whimsical I'm
working on grounding it which is why I
enjoy being in spaces like this because
it helps pull me out of that but I don't
think it's impossible to be able to
build a world like that and I do agree
that people will take advantage of it
right but it's about getting to a point
where they don't have to take advantage
of it where we can educate people about
accountability and making better choices
right but we have to also provide
compassion and understanding before we
do that understand why people in these
situations so you can shift it so what
what happens when you educate people and
they don't care so I'll give you I'll
give you okay I'll give you an example
so I I have a relative okay I'm not
gonna sometimes my family's watching
these lines
now sometimes I'd be a little too
specific in my stories and I hear back
I have a relative and she is someone who
will probably be homeless and on the
street
um and the reason is because she is a
single mom and the reason is because she
made poor decisions where she was an
alcoholic for years and stole from every
every relative until everyone was sick
of taking care of her yeah and so it's
like why does she need to get bailed out
because she makes makes poor decisions
she robbed all of us and and I agree
right again accountability is what led
to those decisions I don't know her her
brother trauma that's what I mean and
that's what I'm saying you have to
understand this and I'm not saying it's
not an excuse right they still take
accountability for that people who have
mental health episodes you're awful to
people still to take accountability for
that but if you can understand the root
of it you can begin to shift generation
you can understand the root and still
take accountability and by dealing with
the consequences is having no one bail
you out like my dad grew up in the same
home he grew up to be a
multi-millionaire with 10 kids and a
beautiful family and so it's like same
house you like and that's what I'm
saying you don't have an excuse like she
doesn't have an excuse she she had the
yeah I have a very like similar family
situation friendly enough it's actually
sorry
I have a barely similar family situation
where my dad was someone who built
himself out of that situation he made
better choices and he provided me the
life I have because he made a decision
to get out and you know the rest of his
family didn't really do that and I've
seen that right and I understand that
but I still think they deserve
compassion for what they've had to
struggle with right some people are
predisposed to making bad choices and
but just based on you know I don't know
I guess
that happened as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible